Hi Crystal, good morning.
Good morning. How are you?
I'm doing great. How about you? How's your week?
Support.
Ohh, it's always exciting and busy.
Alright, you call him.
How about you?
You did bleach your hair?
No.
Mm-mm.
Okay.
I don't, I don't think you recognized it last week, but it's the same.
Okay, now I can see it clearly. All right, just the same. Mine, I'm pretty excited for the coming weekend. So here's Natalie's AI. Okay, let me just quickly share my screen so we can start.
Yeah.
I mean, we can we, yeah, ohh, you be, and then I will think.
Sure.
And I think it is.
recommend.
Do you see it?
Yes, I can see your screen.
All right, perfect. So I'll do this very quickly so I can give you your time back, Crystal. So this is for our April 6th to 17th review. As we all know, we're on our week 27th. So thank you for joining. For the agenda items, all are the same.
And.
And I think.
How do you want?
Yeah, I mean.
check-in and updates, highlights, performance analysis, and open Q&A. For check-in, this is for you. Can you share any feedback or challenges over the past few weeks?
Yeah.
Cortana.
Yeah, right.
Yeah, OK.
No challenges.
The only thing I would ask that John do when he reschedule tickets, because typically he'll reschedule them on someone's schedule for the available time that shows on the calendar. But I would like for him to reach out to the tech
Prior to him scheduling it.
Especially if the ticket has urgency.
behind it. Does that make sense?
So. So if he can look at the look at the detail of the notes in the ticket to specify the urgency of us addressing the matter sooner than later.
Yes, so.
Okay, I got that. So moving forward, we want John Matthew to reach out to the tech first, especially if it's critical or urgent before assigning it to them, right?
Right, to see if we can essentially place it on their calendar before, because I've seen a few instances where he may reschedule it for the next day because that's where the available time is, but the ticket needs to be addressed.
Okay.
Sooner.
Okay, so he's actually rescheduling it for another day.
Right. And this, I'm assuming these are tickets that are in the update required status that he's essentially rescheduling, but we need to just look at the ticket notes, verify if it's something that needs to be. Now, if it's something that doesn't need to be addressed sooner, then
I'm perfectly fine with him scheduling it at their next available time, but if it needs to be addressed sooner, then we want to reach out to the tech to see if they are available.
Okay.
Got that, so it's very critical to triage the ticket first, right? That way we can figure out if it's urgent or what, correct? OK.
Exactly. And just so that you know, and you know, I reached out to you, I think, earlier this week, we're going to move away from using the calendar and we're going to work specifically out of the queue, the tickets that are in the queue.
The only time that we will essentially see tickets that are on the calendar is if there's a specific time that either the end user client requests for us to reach out to them concerning the ticket. And it needs to be specified in the ticket.
Okay, so the only thing that will remain on the dispatch board would be the scheduled tickets, right?
Well, it, they will be on the board.
On the calendar.
Mm.
Right, exactly. They'll be associated in the queue, but for the schedule tickets, that will be specified on their calendars.
Okay, gotcha. So we will have a training placed for this one for everyone, right? Before it will happen, the live Helpdesk model, okay.
Mhm.
Yes, yes.
Cool, cool.
That's what I'm working on now.
Okay, everything good?
Mhm.
Okay, perfect. How soon do you think this will roll out?
Yeah.
I have not quite decided that yet. I just had a meeting yesterday with my managers in regards to the best way or approach to roll this out. And I haven't decided whether this is going to be
H.
Third quarter or the end of this year? I haven't quite decided.
Okay, sure, but it's pretty near, so we'll probably have to work on it. I'll make sure that Matthew will be more familiarized with the ConnectWise managed environment as well as the impact and prioritization, because as far as I can see, that's where we're struggling, right?
Yes.
It's not necessarily a struggle. I think it's more just so training that needs to be applied, implied.
Cortana, anything?
Mhm.
Thank you.
Okay.
Awesome.
All right, so at the end of the day, it's actually, it would depend on how he communicate well with his teammates, right?
Right.
Okay, so I'll make sure to handle that one or our end once he's back. So anything else you wanted to discuss? Okay, good. Okay, thank you, Crystal. Moving on to the highlights, we have two. So we did give him access to Microsoft admin. I did check in with him
No.
That's it for now.
Kip.
the other day, and he was able to work on one L1 ticket that was to provide a delegation of mailbox to a client. And he's very good on identifying if the scope is out of hand. So he did escalate one because of access issues. So
Yeah.
The.
Have you seen it, the ticket?
I did. I didn't necessarily see the ticket, but I was informed that he needed to reassign it to someone else. But
Yes.
I wanted to confirm, was it that client?
Because I didn't confirm this, was it the client was on on-prem? And is that the reason why he didn't have access?
It requires approval. That's why he didn't proceed. Approval from POC.
What was this?
Wow.
So, there.
Well, in that case, he wouldn't necessarily need to escalate the ticket. He just needs to get the approval from
the point of contact.
So you wouldn't need to escalate the ticket for that. Do you have the ticket number?
For the ticket number, I didn't quite get it, but would you like us to discuss once he's back?
Yeah. Let me just check here.
Okay, sure. I'll take note of that.
Yeah, it was a random connect, so I wasn't able to get the details.
Thank us.
Was A Tuesday or a Monday?
Thank you.
Just to verify on this. Just double check. I can't remember the date, but let me just check here. Give me just a second. One.
Okay.
Okay, did you check the database before? I don't know. No. Oh, yeah. Wasn't she checked first email yesterday? I know that's not the right one. We can review it once he's back.
Sure, I'll ping you once I get the ticket number.
So...
Sure. So just kind of to give you more insight in regards to that, I've advised everyone on the team, if we receive a particular request from a end user, if they are not one of the point of contacts or a listed approval,
a person in IT glue, then we would need to get an approval from either the point of contact or their direct supervisor. So any tech can get or speak with the point of contact either by phone or by adding them to the ticket to respond to the ticket with the approval.
So it's just a matter of us properly communicating that to the requester, right? And it's just as simple as to say, we just need to receive approval before we relinquish access to the folder or whatever they're requesting. We need to get and communicate that with the person.
Okay.
Okay, I'll make sure to let him know about this. So we'll review once I have the ticket. I'm not particularly sure if it's for the POC, but that's what I remember. So sorry if I don't have the exact details. Okay, so I'll discuss it with him on Monday.
Sure.
No worries.
Okay, moving on. For the continued collaboration, so I can see that what we have now is working. So let's just keep up. And I appreciate that whenever you have a feedback, you always share it with me. If it's urgent, you always ping me for it. So that way,
OK, yeah.
Vikram.
Gooding.
Home.
Bing.
I need a flat.
we can prevent it from happening in the future. Thank you for that. For performance analysis, this is just the ITBD KPIs. We will use it once we proceed with the new live Helpdesk support, which John Matthew will be included. And so we can continue with the operational readiness
No.
Hi.
Thank you.
flow. This is just the same. So we're on this part where Matthew should be familiarized with the L1 tickets for your clients until the time he will be operating solo.
Yeah, you have fun.
Four.
Here you go.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
What's the talking about?
ITBD by Design products are still the same. If you have inquiries for this one, you can email us or ping me.
I do.
Partner.
And for the way forward, we have the upcoming ITBD holiday. That's May 1st, Philippines Labor Day. Would you need John Matthew to log in, or would you like to give him the holiday off?
Um, let me just check here because...
Our Labor Day is.
Ohh.
It's not until September. Yeah, we would need him that day, May 1st. Yeah.
Okay. All right. I'll cascade that to him as well. And for the last item here, we want to continue with our relationship to sustain the 0 escalation record. For now, I haven't received any SLA breaches from you, so that's a good sign.
No way there.
Just think.
You saying that?
Yeah.
Mick.
So we wanted to make sure that all of any potential escalations will be flagged early. So for example, the P1 and P2 tickets that you reached out to me last time. So I appreciate that as well. So now Matthew is aware of on how to handle it. Also, it's helpful
Like.
Seven.
OK, yeah, so.
Yeah.
Right.
Digital.
The larger.
that we're tracking all of the P1s up to P4s, because that way he will get to know what are the tickets that's listed on P1 until P4. So that's what we're doing as of the moment. Next up, that's the end of my slide. Anything you wanted to discuss?
Yeah.
Instant.
Do that.
That.
Apart from those things, Kris.
Thank you.
No, that's really it. I may be in contact with you to get your thoughts on a few questions that I have with this transition from schedule to live, because I know that you guys have current clients that operate in a live.
State, right?
Yes.
Okay, yeah. So I just may reach out to see to just do some brainstorming and asking questions.
Okay, sure. You can ping me. I'm always available on Teams. And if you wanted to do that as a meeting, I can also include Andrea and other specialists. So if we do them, the meeting, I would recommend to prepare the agenda items.
Are you following me?
Yep.
So that we will have the answer for you beforehand.
Yeah, typically they're just questions, not necessarily a meeting is needed. But if there is, I will certainly let you know.
Yeah.
Okay, I'll start. I'll stop sharing my screen. There you go. Okay, so you can always ping me. That's that. And I hope you have a wonderful weekend, Crystal. Enjoy your time with your family. Bye-bye. Thank you.
Play.
Thank you, you do the Sunny.
Alrighty, you too. Bye-bye.